ça fait déjà plusieurs semaines depuis
la libération de la ville de Carson
aussi au mois de novembre que toutes les
forces russes étaient concentrées dans
le bon base mais depuis hier on reçoit
des signaux un petit peu nouveau de la
part des forces ukrainiennes qui
semblent de plus en plus inquiète sur ce
qui se passe la ville de soledar qui a
seulement quelques kilomètres de
barmouth qui est devenu un petit peu
l'épicentre de ses batailles à l'est du
pays et bien a été prise d'assaut par
des mercenaires du groupe Wagner
également par l'armée russe régulière
c'est une ville qui est assez
stratégique parce qu'il y a de nombreux
tunnels liés à l'extraction de sel et
donc ça pourrait aussi expliquer la
raison pour laquelle les forces russes
veulent absolument s'en emparer prendre
ses villes et ses villages autour de
barmouth c'est aussi un moyen pour les
Russes d'encercler la ville donc baroud
une ville de plus de 100 000 habitants
il en reste 7000 aujourd'hui qui
survivent dans des conditions très
difficiles et selon les autorités
locales près de 60% de la ville de
barmouth et bien a été complètement
détruite
donc aujourd'hui les les stratégies
utilisées par les mercenaires de Wagner
sont plus offensives et plus violentes
selon l'armée ukrainienne ce qui
explique des bilans plus importants et
des combats plus féroces que lorsque
c'est tout simplement l'armée régulière
russe qui agit avec des manœuvres et des
tactiques militaires plus classiques les
dernières personnes civiles évacuées
évoquaient des combats avec des armes
automatiques dans la ville qu'il pouvait
entendre des temps que qui se tiraient
les uns sur les autres donc on sent bien
que c'est une situation vraiment très
difficile extrême et pendant ce temps et
bien les frappes continuent dans
d'autres zones du paysageson aussi qui
avait été libéré la gare continue et il
semble que les Ukrainiens craignent ces
prochaines heures vont être décisives
concernant bar mouth et l'est du pays
bonjour Astrid l'Ukraine et la Russie se
livre aussi une bataille de
communication féroce autour de frappes
russes sur des casernes à Kramatorsk
oui absolument alors il faut rappeler
que déjà il y avait une frappe
ukrainienne un macificat une ville donc
occupée par les forces russes depuis
2014 où les Ukrainiens infirmé avoir tué
plus de 400 soldats russes les Russes
avaient démenti le bilan même s'ils
avaient reconnu avoir eu des pertes et
parler d'un bilan de 89 soldat mort et
donc c'est après cela que vient cette
annonce par le ministre de la Défense
russe qui affirme avoir tué plus de 600
soldats Ukrainiens accrématorsk les
Ukrainiens ont immédiatement démenti le
bilan même s'ils ont reconnu des frappes
il y a eu cette missiles qui auraient
touché la ville de crématorz mais il
parle d'un bilan beaucoup moins
important critique la Russie parle de
propagande concernant ces chiffres alors
il n'y a pas eu pour l'instant de bilan
indépendant donc il faut prendre avec
précaution tous les chiffres que l'on
entend mais il semblerait aussi selon
des journalistes présents sur place à
crémator ce que les frappes auraient
fait moins de 600 personnes des
personnes qui ont pu constater les
dégâts
parler d'immeubles plus petit qui sans
doute accueillaient un petit peu moins
de soldats Ukrainiens mais ce qui est
sûr c'est que la bataille concrètement
continue et la bataille de la
communication également